an uncharted island let me list all the
ways you're gonna die
brain heat disease-carrying flies and we
haven't started on the things that want
to beat your life will double there plus
a bonus if we make it back if in this
video part of the city with a son
[Music]
[Applause]
I'll XML for FX guide.com for Wyatt
looking at ILM screechers on Kong's
Skull Island since in 1933 audiences
have been going to the cinema to see
King Kong and since that original
brilliant stop frame animation of Kong
by Willis O'Brien audiences have also
been wound by visual effects in 2017
it's al M's turned to bring Kong to life
along with an incredibly oppressive
array of spiders or water buffalo even
evil scholar for Academy award-winning
VFX supervisor Steven Rosenbaum joined
the film even before the script was done
and in those really early days he got a
number of companies art departments to
work on some early ideas one of the
film's most difficult character
animation moments comes directly from
one of those early pencil sketches done
by MPC of Kong just sitting and eating
squid this arresting Li simple shot
requires water Simms flesh Simms facial
animation complex fur grooming not to
mention detailed compositing Toby
Kebbell plays Jack Chapman in the scene
and he's actually playing Kong opposite
himself because Tobey provided the
motion capture that ILM used on their
film Warcraft and so the team reused him
here so not only is he in the film but
he provided the facial capture for Kong
which the animators referenced except of
course Toby got to eat Twizzlers all day
long instead of live squid Kong has 19
million hairs but with various render
controls that would allow an artist to
dial in and reduce the settings maybe
decimate the hair count or use fatter
thus less hairs
I even had a camera culling tool that
would drop out any hairs that wouldn't
be seen by the camera in any particular
shot and of course all this is just
useful stuff to get shots through a
production pipeline now one of the other
really great Ferg rooms was actually the
water buffalo scene earlier in the film
the hair grooming team was headed by
gamer and and she also did the complex
hair and fur work in Aisle M's Warcraft
where the new hair crafts tool was
developed Gayle personally did the water
buffalo and Islands visual effects
supervisor Jeff white names this close
the water buffalo is one of his favorite
CG character shots at the entire film
well the water buffalos body here was
done in pretty much in the same way as
Kong's the ILM effects team grew and
digitally simulated the seaweed that
interacts with the horns because it
comes off the water meanwhile a third
team the environment team did the back
of the water buffalo using Clarisse a
tool they would normally just use for
vegetation and environments on set the
actors were looking at pretty much
nothing at all now they'd seen some
artwork but the rest of its just down to
their good acting the environment is
real just the Buffalo and the water
around him is digital and this was
pretty much in line with the film's
general approach of filming at real
locations whenever possible the team
went through many iterations to arrive
at the final look and design of the
skull crawlers these beasts were a
combination of designs from the art
department and ILM and the primary look
was that of a three-legged reptilian
beasts with a very defined skull head
the inspiration for the skull crawlers
came from kaboom
yes the director's initial reference
given to Steven Rosenbaum for the evil
giant three-legged skull crawling
killers was Pokemon Capone we're going
to forget subscribe for more behind the
scenes action
I'm Mike Seymour for wide
you